hello freak [ __ ] right and I said to
a lot the last time I saw the two of you
you were like kissing I'm telling you so
how much he loved each other and then
like 16 years passes and it's the worst
like divorce that Texas has ever known
it's Stefan that's what divorce lawyers
were saying like it was it's the worst
are they just cause of one national and
they just hate you so this isn't
actually named each other so I said like
yeah and now alex has got a staff of
like 75 people you know with like these
giant tigers for his supplemental male
vitality supplements have you ever seen
the video of when Joey Diaz and me are
in Alex's studio and Joey realizes that
it's on the internet so because it's on
the internet he could say whatever he
wants so we go we go live and Alex goes
uh well actually from here on our on the
internet so you kind of say whatever you
want but try to keep it clean and the
look of for Joey Diaz it was like the
cat who saw the canary and realized that
the cage was open and he had so he's
telling some story about smuggling weed
through the airport listen to this stop
listen to your [ __ ] congressman or
your [ __ ] governor or your [ __ ]
presence of the political resident and
he's taking that same [ __ ] they give
you every four [ __ ] years and you
still vote for the [ __ ] Momo and then
you get mad think about me saying the
word [ __ ] with that I'm out I got a
local Donna never gonna make another
very solid points don't do no I know I
know you get it question but there's
just to let the American public know
that every four years they buy the same
[ __ ] they've been violated for years at
the same people with 7,000 Harvard
articulation and the how they don't
curse and they're Christians and they
have a family and these are the same
people that shove it up your [ __ ] ass
every year the one thing that you get
about me I'll say [ __ ] but I will not
[ __ ] rob you if I need something I'll
ask you like a matter
hey go [ __ ] yourself you cut hold on
hold on one second take a joke take a
shuttle
Joey da Facebook Twitter check yourself
before you wreck yourself
big Dixon yes I'll get out of here
you're in trouble I'm on the unpowered
fire this is wrong all right let's go
black cause it's the most important okay
okay hey he made Alex Pete oh he's a
point where it's ever lived
do you think Alex regrets all of it now
eyes great I have a good time without I
know I own you know when I say all of
this I mean to think Alex regrets the
fact that though you know that the
spotlight is on him in there is kind of
unfair oh no I don't think a part of him
it's like stressed out what honestly
sign he I've never met a guy in my life
that has more Teflon when it comes to
stress like welcoming koster us out
lately but I go to the gym I feel fine
got a cheeseburger probably shouldn't
have that [ __ ] trying to stick to my
diet that's hard
he isn't give a [ __ ] man but he he's a
weird guy like he's got a very unusual
Constitution
[Applause]
[Music]
you